Hast du beim Netz irgendwas anders als letztes Jahr?
Ich bin auf LTE, keine Ahnung.
Also es ist mit dem WLAN an sich, also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie so eure Erfahrungen sind. Mann, heute ist aber auch hier wirklich der Wurm drin.
Ich hab jetzt langsam echt keinen Bock mehr.
Was ist denn hier los? Altscheißerl!
Der gewünschte Podcast ist zur Zeit leider nicht verfügbar.
Die weitere Sendung verzögert sich um 30 Minuten.
Endlich mal wieder hier reinatmen.
Atmen. Test 1, 2, 3.
Dennis, wo ist denn Roddy?
Wo ist denn Roddy? Roddy!
Roddy. Oh man ey, ich hab ihm echt gesagt 22.30 Uhr.
Kann was wurschtlich sein?
Exzentrika.
Aber ich dachte, Dennis sollte in diesem Einhornkostüm auf die Bühne kommen.
Ja, wir könnten unsere Kopfhörer, glaube ich, ein bisschen lauter gebrochen.
Ah, mach später.
Bitte? Ja, wir nennen das Einhorn jetzt einfach Clemens. Sieht ja auch so ähnlich aus. Mal gucken, ob es sich auch ähnlich verhalten wird. Ja, herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freak Show, Ausgabe Nummer 190, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche. Und wir sind live auf dem 33C3. Und es sind eine Menge Leute da. Und ich sage Hallo. Vielen Dank fürs Kommen schon mal. Ist es schön da, Roddy?
Brauchst du Wasser?
Brauchst du Hilfe? Ist es gut?
Ja, weckt mich auf, wenn ich schnarche. Bestimmt.
Ich jedes Jahr komme ich hierher und denke mir, wer hört eigentlich die Freak Show? Und dann sitzen hier plötzlich alle. Verrückt.
Ja, wir haben uns natürlich nicht vorbereitet, ist ja klar, weil ist ja eigentlich auch, ist irgendwas passiert dieses Jahr?
Kaum.
Kaum, genau. Ja, und von daher ist jetzt die Frage, ob wir überhaupt noch irgendwie, ob wir uns jetzt überhaupt noch irgendwie steigern können.
Ist alles gesagt worden.
Na, ist eigentlich schon alles gesagt worden. Vielleicht noch nicht ganz von jedem, aber in gewisser Hinsicht. Ich hab im Übrigen, also ist ja relativ selten hier, aber für den Fall eines Internet-Ausfalls wurde mir gerade von einem Hörer ein Web-Adressbuch bereitgestellt. Vielen Dank dafür. Das Web-Adressbuch für Deutschland ausgewählt die 5000 besten Webseiten aus dem Internet. Und solange uns halt nichts Besseres einfällt, werden wir einfach mal da ein bisschen vorlesen. Aber wir können natürlich auch noch mal so ein bisschen allgemeines Feedback und Blick in die Zeit machen. Wäre ja auch so eine Sache, ne? Ich hab übrigens, habt ihr diese Story gehört mit diesen Passwörtern, dass die Leute... Na ja, es sind ja immer dieselben. Also die Leute wählen immer dieselben Passwörter und Passwörter, die sie sich halt gut merken können.
Du meinst Platz 10.
Was war auf Platz 10? Ich hab's nicht gehört.
Ist öffentlich-rechtlich, das darf ich nicht sagen.
Ach so, das Wort.
Das Holgi-Wort.
Ja, nee, ich wollte eigentlich auf Platz 4 zu sprechen kommen.
Und das war?
Platz 4 ist so ein Wort, was eigentlich auch jeder kennt, sonst wär's ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht auf Platz 4. Aber was mir dabei aufgefallen ist, dass es sich wahrscheinlich bei diesem Wort, um den zumindest in Deutschland bekanntesten alphanumerischen String handelt.
Bier?
Bier ist ja kein alphanumerischer String, sondern ist ja nur ein Alphastring.
Test 1, 2, 3?
War das auf Platz 2, dann bin ich geliefert.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaub nicht. Also der auf Platz 4 war Schalke 04. Und so hab ich dann noch nie drüber nachgedacht.
Das waren Fake News.
Ja, nee, was ist heutzutage nicht Fake News, aber ist ja auch egal. Es ist eine Themenvorlage, die müssen wir aufgreifen.
So ist es halt.
Ja, aber denk mal so darüber nach. Was hat man als Nerd für Probleme, so für uns gängige Begriffe wie Alphanumerik zu erklären?
Du meinst mit Schalke 04 geht das?
Ja!
Das verstehen die sofort.
Da kannst du mit deinem Union nicht mithalten.
So brauchst du mir jetzt nicht zu kommen.
Aber ist so, ist nicht alphanumerisch.
Es ist der erste FC-Union in Berlin.
Gibt es das als Passwort?
Ja, es ist vielleicht auch ein Passwort, aber es ist nicht auf Platz 4.
Aber es ist sicherer.
Erste FC-Union in Berlin ist definitiv ein sicheres Passwort. Falls ihr euch versprochen habt, von diesem Kongress mit einem sicheren Passwort nach Hause zu gehen, wir empfehlen euch erste FC-Union in Berlin. Ihr könnt es dann variieren mit Leerzeichen.
Ich würde ja so einen türkischen Verein empfehlen.
Ja, welcher?
Ich kann den nicht aussprechen.
Ja, aber sind die auch alphanumerisch? Das ist ja sozusagen die Qualität. Also halten wir fest, Schalke 04 ist wahrscheinlich einfach der bekannteste alphanumerische String. Und es ist halt nebenbei auch noch ein guter Cue, um halt auf so einer bierseligen Küchenparty Leuten das zu erklären, was das ist. Alphanumerisch, genau. Ja, was ist ein Alphanumer? Du mit deinen Nerd-Worten und so. Schalke 04, alles klar.
Ey, hast du meinen Verein als alphanumerisch bezeichnet?
Das würde ich doch niemals tun.
Jetzt sitzen wir hier so mit Kopfhörern. Ist ja immer so eine Sache. Das machen ja auch nur Podcaster, so auf einer Bühne rum sitzen und dann so Headphones, weil die anderen, die immer so auf Bühnen sind, sind ja immer der Meinung, das sehe nicht gut aus oder so, oder es würde einen irgendwie entstellen, oder keine Ahnung, was die Leute so denken.
Dem stimme ich voll und ganz zu.
Dass sie das tun oder dass die Leute das denken?
Dass das so ist.
Aber die Profisendungen, die haben schon auch Kopfhörer und Mikro nur, sieht man die nicht so. Die haben halt die guten, kleinen, durchsichtigen Hautfarben.
Ja, aber das ist in ihr.
Und das ist scheiße?
Also ich bin ja so für in ihr, also... Der einzige in ihr, den ich akzeptieren würde, wäre ein Babelfisch.
Wegen dir müssen wir alle leiden.
Wegen mir? Wieso denn wegen mir? Was hab ich denn damit zu tun?
Na wegen dir muss ich doch so ein Ding tragen und nicht dieses andere.
Ach so, wegen mir, ja.
Wegen denen.
Denen ist das ja egal.
Was? Nee, der Punkt ist doch, wenn du jetzt keinen Kopfhörer aufhättest, dann wärst du ja quasi aus unserer unmittelbaren Kommunikation weitgehend entzogen. Das ist ja der Effekt, wenn du jetzt nur ein Mikrofon hast, hörst du nicht. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt hier mit dem Mikrofon steht und versucht da rein zu kommunizieren, hört man sich selber nicht, weil dahinten ist natürlich viel lauter, aber hier ist leise, weil wir keine Monitorboxen haben.
Warum haben wir keine Monitorboxen? Weil wir Kopfhörer aufhaben. Also wir könnten noch Monitorboxen haben.
Ja, aber dann wäre das halt blöd, dann hätten wir nämlich nicht so gute Mikrofone, weil wir haben ja Kondensator-Mikrofone und wenn wir jetzt mit Monitorboxen arbeiten und Kondensator-Mikrofone, das geht halt irgendwie überhaupt nicht. Jetzt ruft Clemens an.
Wo ist Letty? Sie ist hier am Strand, die wollte Live-Bilder schicken.
Also zur Erklärung, also Letty ist verhindert und Clemens sitzt entweder jetzt gerade noch im Flugzeug oder ist gerade gelandet, das weiß ich nicht.
Du meinst, er hat mehr Netz als wir?
Der hatte vorhin mich schon aus dem Flugzeug aus ange-Facetimed, sagt man das so, und meinte, das würde wahrscheinlich nicht klappen. Jetzt hat er natürlich gerade irgendwie eben angerufen. Jetzt muss ich mal kurz hier die Kommunikation aufnehmen. Während ich versuche, meinen großartigen Gedanken rund um Kopfhörer noch halbwegs erfolgreich hier zu Ende zu bringen, das ist natürlich schwierig.
Wir wollen Monitor wechseln.
Mein Kurzvor-WLAN-Card.
Ja, okay, Triads sag ich mal. Aber mit dem Adresse, die wir nicht nennen.
Schalke 04.
Kurzer Hinweis an die Regie. Ihr könntet mal auf dem iMac schauen, dass ihr das komische Facetime-Programm startet. Und mit ein bisschen Glück ruft Clemens da gleich an und dann könnten wir den onscreen bringen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Ja, vielleicht.
Ahja, die haben es mitbekommen.
Und wir haben eine Kamera in die Regie jetzt.
Ihr könnt den auch mal anrufen. Klickt mal ruhig auf Video, das ist schon okay, sonst kriegen wir nämlich kein Bild.
Genau da drauf und dann schauen wir mal, ob wir den kriegen.
Zu den Kopfhörern. Um den Gedanken nochmal zu Ende zu bringen.
Ich finde nämlich so...
Willkommen im Freak Show Audio-Video-Setup.
Clemens Lübbel ist für Facetime nicht verfügbar. Na ja, also... Das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Weil er ist für uns nicht verfügbar.
Also bei den Kopfhörern ist das auf jeden Fall eine tolle Sache, weil man ja einfach dann so schön untereinander kommunizieren kann, als würde man direkt nebeneinander sitzen.
Tun wir natürlich jetzt auch.
Aber es ist genau das Problem. Was? Ja, weil wir unterhalten uns jetzt so, als wären wir in der Metaebene und würden Pizza essen und Bier trinken. Aber dann schwenke ich meinen Kopf irgendwie 45 Grad nach rechts oder auch 90 sogar. Und sehe plötzlich so eine ganze Wand von Menschen.
Wir könnten das ja fixen, indem wir uns Heimvideos schicken lassen. Und die bringen wir dann die ganze Zeit während der Sendung auf den Beamer.
Oder wir machen das so DJ-mäßig mit einem Up.
Ja, die Stimme der Jugend. Immer mit frischen Ideen am Start. Kopfhörer sind auf jeden Fall eine tolle Sache, denn Kopfhörer stellen Intimität her. Clemens! Hallo, hallo! Nick mal, also ich weiß nicht, noch können wir dich nicht hören, aber das können wir vielleicht gleich noch gefixt bekommen. Clemens sitzt noch im Flugzeug sogar.
Schnell, sag irgendjemand was über DNS oder Telekom.
Ah, da bist du. Clemens, super. Wir müssten mal, vielleicht können wir den iMac, kriegt ihr den iMac irgendwie noch gedreht aufs Publikum? Das wär ja geil, weil dann wüsstest du auch mal so, in etwa wo wir sind. Pass auf, dass die Kabel nicht rausrutschen.
Und bist angeschnallt, Clemens.
Guck mal Clemens, hier, da, guck mal, dein Publikum. Erzähl doch mal kurz deine Ist-Situation, solange du noch WLAN hast.
Ist-Situation ist, dass das WLAN gleich ausgeht. Wir landen nämlich demnächst in Singapur. Und jetzt so gerade noch ein Stückchen über Malaysia. Also mitten über dem Indischen Ozean sozusagen noch.
Und was machst du da?
Ich sitze jetzt hier so.
Was du so in Singapur machst, man.
In Singapur verbringe ich erst mal Silvester und dann fliege ich weiter nach Neuseeland.
Werd nicht zu spezifisch. Zu viele Details könnten uns verwirren.
Und vor allen Dingen die ganzen Groupies in deine Richtung senden.
Ja, hier oben gibt es nicht so viele Groupies. Es gibt ein paar von unseren Groupies in Asien. Den habe ich ja in Seoul schon getroffen sogar.
Wie gesagt, nicht zu viele Details.
Die Gruppiedichte ist nicht so hoch wie in Hamburg.
Das heißt Hörerinnen.
Ihr habt ja da ein geiles Einhorn.
Genau, wir haben ein geiles Einhorn. Ihr seid ja mittlerweile sogar auf die Bühne gerichtet. Das Einhorn verdeckt uns. Kannst du das Einhorn mal in die andere Richtung? Ach, das ist ja hier wirklich moderne Technik. Großartig. Genau.
Da hinten winken irgendwelche Pixel. Hi Roddy. Roddy kann dich erkennen, die anderen.
Verstehe, es ist sozusagen pixeluit. Ja, hast du noch einen Schwank aus deinem Flugleben zu erzählen?
Ähm, Schwank.
Das ist eine Unterhaltungssendung.
Das ist live hier.
Das ist 13 Stunden Fliegerei hier und die verbringt man halt mit Schlafessen, Kacken.
Hier sitzen sie. Das waren schon wieder zu viele Details.
Na ja gut. Hättest du ja auch was einfallen lassen können.
Also, ja stimmt, ich bin schlecht vorbereitet.
Ich geb's zu.
Aber wir haben eine Technologie-Demonstration gemacht.
Aber es ist trotzdem noch eine schöne Show, oder?
Genau, aber vielleicht kannst du ja sicherlich beantworten. Wer ist denn da der Provider?
Wir sind hier, Singapore Airlines.
Technik von Panasonic. Da kann euch die Annalena mehr zu erzählen, die weiß das.
Du nicht, weil du kennst sie nicht so gut aus.
Ah, nein, doch noch da.
Mit WLAN kennst du dich nicht so gut aus. Und wie schnell ist das?
Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, weil das... Das ist auch ein bisschen eingeschränkt. Wenn man ordentliche Sachen machen will, bei denen muss man ein bisschen VPN aufmachen. Oder VPN würde jetzt Facetime auch nicht gehen. Aber wie gesagt, mit VPN kann man das alles spielen. Und funktioniert, wie du siehst. Ja, super. Jetzt gibt es hier gerade 1000 tolle Ansagen. Die Kinder gehen an mit, okay, wir schützen gerade ein bisschen... Wir ernähren den Boden. Das heißt, demnächst geht es ein bisschen das Netz hier auch aus. Ich wünsche euch noch eine tolle Show da. Und einen schönen Kongress.
Ja, super Clemens. Vielen Dank für die Reise. Und wir sprechen uns noch.
Danke. Bis dann.
Kleinen Applaus.
Perfektes Timing, würde ich sagen, oder? Aber der rückt ja auch nicht raus mit den Details, ne?
Schlimm.
Aber was ich noch zu Kopfhörern sagen wollte. Ich finde ja Kopfhörer wirklich toll. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das schon mal aufgegangen ist. Und es gibt doch auch noch so eine spezifische Kulturform, die durch Kopfhörer ermöglicht wird, die ist wirklich bemerkenswert. Und da wurde mir gerade wirklich von einer sehr lustigen Variante erzählt. Und zwar rede ich von Kopfhörer-Partys. Wisst ihr, was das ist?
Er leuchtet uns.
Also ich weiß schon, was das ist, aber war das nicht so vor zehn Jahren cool?
Ja.
Jetzt hat's Tim auch gehört.
Aber vor zehn Jahren waren da Kabel dran. Also für die Unerleuchteten unter euch, Kopfhörer-Partys sind stille Partys, wo Leute, die sozusagen an dieser Party teilnehmen, Kopfhörer aufhaben. Und die DJen spielen die Musik quasi auf diese Kopfhörer. Ich hatte das so früher in den frühen Prenzlauer Berg, in Party-Zeiten gab's dann so große Kabelspinnen, die aus 3, 4, 5 Meter Höhe nach unten gingen und die Leute flochten sozusagen da in endloses Band mit der Zeit. Hat aber relativ gut funktioniert und war natürlich schon mal bemerkenswert, weil man quasi mitten in der Stadt einfach eine fette Party feiern konnte. Hat aber natürlich die entsprechenden Einschränkungen.
Man kann sich nicht unterhalten.
Na ja, das kannst du auf so einer Party, geh doch mal da runter in die Lounge, da kannst du dich auch nicht unterhalten.
Doch!
Na ja, indem du dich laut anschreist.
Das funktioniert dann auch noch.
Aber der Punkt ist ja, dass du sozusagen in einer Situation bist, in der du überhaupt eine Party überhaupt erst machen kannst. Technology enables culture.
Und das gleiche machen wir jetzt ohne Kabel und verdrehen.
Genau, jetzt gibt's das Ganze ja in Funk. Und das hat halt nicht nur den Vorteil, dass du dich nicht mehr in irgendwelche anderen Kabel eindrehst, sondern man kann das Ganze auch noch diversifizieren. Und das Video, was ich gesehen habe, mitnebst einer Schilderung dieser Situation, war ganz vorzüglich, weil diese Kopfhörer, die dort zum Einsatz kamen, deren spezifisches Modell ich leider nicht benennen kann, aber wenn von euch irgendeiner da draußen das weiß, das will ich unbedingt haben, das ist so cool. Das sind Kopfhörer, die, ich weiß nicht, Bluetooth wird's nicht sein, das ist irgendwie Funk. Und soweit sind sie erst mal ganz normale Kopfhörer, aber sie haben dann an den Seiten LEDs. Und du kannst dann mit einem Schalter zwischen drei Quellen umschalten. Und je nachdem, welche Quelle du hast, leuchtet halt rot, grün oder blau. Und auf dieser Party gab's halt drei DJs gleichzeitig, die alle nebeneinander standen, alle ihre eigene Musik spielten. Und es war sozusagen so ein Real-Time-Battle darum, wer springt auf meine Musik auf?
Welche Farbe sieht man am meisten?
Genau, welche Farbe sieht man am meisten. Du kannst sozusagen immer diese tanzende Crowd sehen, wo dann halt so, was weiß ich, 30% rot irgendwie, 50% blau und welche Zahl auch immer dann auch mal rauskommt.
20?
Ja, wenn du das sagst. Und man merkt ja dann immer so richtig so, dann wurde die Musik irgendwie so ein bisschen tranig und die andere Farbe wurde dann auf einmal so alle voll wild und voll geil. Und dann so klack, klack, klack, klack, klack, änderten sich sozusagen die Farben und die DJs konnten immer live dazu schauen, wie gut gerade ihre Musik ankam.
Und du willst das für Podcasts in der U-Bahn?
Ich hätte das gerne für den Congress. Du könntest halt hier rumlaufen und die ganze Zeit irgendeinem Talk zuhören und du würdest aber in der Farbe sehen, welcher Saal das jetzt gerade ist.
Zum Beispiel.
Oh, da ist Post gekommen.
Das ist mein Kabel.
Das finde ich ja überhaupt geil. Das Ding lief ja die ganze Zeit nicht. Und jetzt ist auf einmal hier die Seidenstraße aktiv. Bläst locker vor sich hin. Hübsch gestrickt hier mit so einem kleinen wie nennt man diese Kübel? Beton, Zementkübel sind das, ne? Was ist das denn?
Das sieht dildoesk aus.
Die Frage ist, ist was drin? Aber ich fürchte nicht.
Das sieht hübsch aus.
Ist das 3D?
Ist das 3D? Ist das 3D?
Gib mal den Deckel.
Geil, oh. Guck mal, Batterien drin, Innaloops, richtig geil. Nicht mehr diese blöden Knopfzellen und immer wieder wegschmeißen. Hier gibt es allerdings noch ein Compartment, da braucht man aber Kreuzschlitz. Also ich glaube, die kamen einfach nur an.
Sieht aus wie eine Turbine.
Ja, sieht sehr schick aus. Aber was ich jetzt gerade so beeindruckt war, ist, dass jetzt hier so eine... Wie sagt man? Gewinde.
Danke, Binnis.
Du bist mein Wörterbuch heute.
Normalerweise fehlen mir immer die Wörter.
Aber dass so ein Gewinde sich so gut produzieren lässt, dass es bestimmt da irgendwie reingeschweißt oder so.
Geschnitzt. Aber warum ist da nichts drin? Wir hatten das Problem noch schon letztes Jahr.
Müssen wir uns nicht weiter von ablenken lassen. Was haltet ihr denn jetzt von meinem tollen Kopfhörervorschlag?
Ich dachte, du hättest ein Video, was du uns jetzt vorführst, da drüber.
Ja, ich hab das nur auf einem Someone Else's Device gesehen. Kann da jetzt leider nicht drauf linken. Nichts in die Show Notes.
Also ich sag mal... Ich glaube nicht an Kopfhörerpartys.
Du glaubst nicht an Kopfhörerpartys. Roddy, du sagst die ganze Zeit nix. Du könntest jetzt meiner Idee den Todesstoß geben.
Und unterhalten sich dann auch noch?
Na dann, würd ich sagen.
Ui, neues Programm.
Seid ihr mit dem nächsten Thema dran?
Was habt ihr davon?
Ja, ich habe auch gerade hier Medien auf fremden Medien, das Lounge-Programm für unten zu Gesicht bekommen. Für alle, die es noch nicht gefunden haben, es ist jetzt im Wiki. Es gibt morgen zum Beispiel ein großes Highlight in der Lounge, denn aerobik gibt sich die Ehre. Ich glaube von 0 Uhr bis 2 Uhr? Übermorgen. Nee, da stand an Tag 3 drin, oder? Übermorgen. Nee.
Null Uhr ist...
Welcher Tag ist heute? Ja, dann übermorgen. Oh man, dieser Congress, ne? Aber es ist jetzt im Wiki, also für alle, die Zweifel haben und sich jetzt noch mehr konfus fühlen als vorher, einfach ins Wiki schauen. Das mein kleiner Programmtipp.
Vielleicht erklärst du ja auch nochmal, was es damit auf sich hat.
Mit aerobik oder der Lounge? Oder dem Wiki?
Sowohl als auch. Aber ich glaube, dass mit der Lounge hat sich den meisten Anwesenden schon erschlossen. Aber du musst ja immer bedenken, wir übertragen ja weltweit, global ins Internet. Und es gibt Menschen, die vielleicht jetzt hier einfach vollkommen so, Lounge? Ich hab gar keine Lounge in meinem Zimmer.
Aber es wird doch wohl jeder Freak Show-Hörer schon mindestens einmal auf dem Congress gewesen sein.
Du weißt doch, Argumente kriegt man am besten dadurch unter, indem man sie fortwährend wiederholt.
Also für die Hörer da draußen an den Hörgeräten, wer noch nicht an diesem Congress teilgenommen hat, erste Amtshandlung schreibt an uns. Was hatten wir? Stachelbeerkuchen hatten wir schon, ne? Sag mal einen Kuchen, den du nicht magst. Okay, Rhabarberkuchen an uns zwittern, wenn ihr das jetzt hört und noch nie auf einem Congress wart. Für diejenigen, erklären wir jetzt kurz die Lounge, oder was?
Und aerobik.
Und aerobik. Vor zwei Jahren, na das ist jetzt viel zu schwer. Kommt einfach auf den Kongress.
Du machst das jetzt so einfach.
Ich kann doch jetzt nicht die Lounge erklären. Das ist wie, du fängst Harald Lesch an zu gucken und drei Tage später fällt dir auf, dass du durstig wirst und musst aufstehen und was trinken.
Ja, aber auch das, weißt du, das ist das Problem, wenn man irgendwas vermitteln möchte, dann muss man auch Dinge, die für einen selber sehr selbstverständlich klingen, trotzdem hergeleitet bekommen.
Hörbar erfahrbar machen.
Ja, man muss das ja irgendwie rinkriegen in die Köppe. Weil wenn die dann nicht dieselbe Terminologie sprechen, dann bist du ja komplett aufgeschmissen.
Dann gucken die dich an und denken nur so, also hier auf dem Congress sind ja Vorträge und unter einer Lounge wird der Vortrag am praktischen Beispiel vorgeführt. Die Party am praktischen Beispiel.
Mit solchen Co-Moderatoren muss man erstmal eine Sendung hinkriegen. Roddy, was ist denn mit dir los eigentlich?
Was möchtest du wissen?
Was hältst du denn von der Lounge eigentlich?
Wie geht's dir auf dem Einhorn? Super! Ich könnte dir jetzt mal im Telefonbuch was nachschlagen auch.
Bitte werfen Sie eine Münze ein.
Du willst doch schon wieder Zeit schinden.
Nein, ich hab noch mehr Themen, so ist ja nicht.
Bitte werfen Sie eine Münze ein.
Roddy hat den Film gesehen.
Da war ich bei den Kasten heute.
Und ich hab den Automaten gefunden.
Den gibt es auf dem Kongress? Den gibt es auf dem Kongress. Den gibt es auf dem Kongress?
Den Glücksmelodie-Automaten. Wo werfen Sie eine Münze ein?
Wo denn?
Hier drunter.
Wenn man vor dem Infodesk steht, die Säule rechts davor.
Die Säule rechts davor, alles klar.
Und da ist was dann?
Der Glücksmelodie-Automat.
Du musst eine Münze einwerfen. Dann kommen noch so ein paar andere Sachen, die verraten wir nicht. Und da musst du noch so eine Frage beantworten. Die verraten wir aber auch nicht, ist besser. Und dann kriegst du dann eine persönliche, exklusive, nur für dich ausgewählte Glücksmelodie. Genau. Und dann musst du ja auch noch nachspielen. Sonst hast du kein Glück. Und das ist dann deine Melodie für dein Leben.
Aber ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil ich habe diesen Film in der Freak Show ungefähr 23 bis 13.000 Mal beworben. Und du hast ihn offensichtlich immer noch nicht gesehen. Nach all den Jahren, Tim.
Ich bin tief enttäuscht.
Na, wo der lustige Glücksmelodie automat herkommt.
Ich ahne, glaube ich, schon, um welchen Film es sich handelt. Ich habe ihn mir neulich noch mal auf meine Liste nach oben gesetzt.
Jetzt Publikumsinteraktion. Wer von euch hat noch nie im Leben keinen Pardon mit Harpe Kerkeling gesehen?
Ich hab's geahnt.
Siehst du, siehst du, ich bin nicht allein.
Sie können nicht die Hand heben.
Na, jetzt Gegenprobe.
Wer hat's gesehen?
Das sind weniger.
Und wer fand den auch gut?
Schmupp, wegmachen.
So ist das.
Alle, die jetzt noch die Hand gehoben haben, wir trinken nachher ein Bier in der Lounge.
Kommen wir zu ermunternden, rennenden Tim?
Moment, Moment. Wo wir gerade bei Congress-Lokalitäten sind. Ich hab noch eine Mission. Die wichtigsten Missionen sind schon abgeschlossen, aber eine der wichtigen Missionen ist, den Cyborg-Schwarzmarkt zu finden. Hat jemand von euch schon den Cyborg-Schwarzmarkt auf dem Congress gefunden? Noch niemand.
Den Cyborg-Schwarzmarkt? Wo es so gebrauchte Roboterbeine gibt, oder was?
Naja, nee, das Konzept ist, es werden Cyborgs ausgestellt, aber daneben gibt es noch einen Schwarzmarkt, wo sozusagen Spare Parts, so unter der Ladentheke, verkauft ein Vakuum, eingeschweißt, Weltraum, reisekompatibel.
Der Erbauer sitzt hier in der ersten Reihe, heißt es hier gerade.
Und wo ist der?
Es gibt keine Antwort. Oben.
Das typische an einem Schwarzmarkt ist, dass es nicht offensichtlich ist, wo er ist.
Einfach klare Ansage. Okay, ich hab noch was zu tun auf dem Congress. Auf jeden Fall, da könnten wir auch noch ein Bier trinken am Cyborg-Schwarzmarkt, wenn wir es vielleicht irgendwann finden.
Ja.
Was ja auch viel gesucht wird, sind diese Rätsel.
Super Brücke.
Das Spiel, was es nicht gibt.
There is no game.
Hat jemand daran teilgenommen von euch?
Nee, ich hab vorhin nur zugeguckt.
Aha.
Ich hörte davon.
Du hörtest davon, dass Dennis dabei zugeschaut hat.
Wie jemand davon erzählte.
Wie kommen wir hier zwischendurch?
Das kommt ein bisschen unangenehm rüber.
Hier unten, auch hinter dem Info-Tresen, ein bisschen weiter ist eine quadratische Säule. Da ist ein selbstgebautes Plexiglass-Schloss, würde ich mal behaupten, oder Acrylglas. Wir kennen ja, wo das herkommt. Das kommt ja aus Berliner Umfeld, dieses Schloss. Das hab ich ja mitbekommen. Aber daneben ist da noch so ein Eingabefeld. Da standen ganz viele Nerds rum und versuchten wild, irgendwelche Codes einzugeben. Und das gerät immer, komm mal später wieder. Oder probier nochmal.
Schalke 04.
Numerisch, nicht alphanumerisch.
Ja, das Tastenfeld war numerisch oder was? Die Ausgabe war Text.
Na ja, kannst ja ASCII-Code eingeben.
Und weiter?
Na, dann haben die lang probiert. Und dann, eine Frau hat's dann geschafft. Und dann waren die ganz happy mit ihrer Gruppe. Und dann sind die weitergezogen. Die haben dann sozusagen sich ihren nächsten Level da erspielt. Die mussten den Schlüssel reinstecken. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube vorne am Schlüssel war ein USB-Stück dran. Kann das sein? Ja, den ist so. Das sah so aus.
Das ist wie unsere Heizungsdiskussion. Keiner weiß genau.
Aber die auch nicht. Du steckst den rein und dann musst du drehen. Dadurch wird das wahrscheinlich aktiviert. Und dann kommt da halt die Frage, dass du was eingeben sollst.
Und wenn es zu warm ist, machen wir das Fenster auf.
Habe ich oben das Fenster öffnen lassen? Weil hier ist ja so warm wegen dem 1400er. Du weißt schon, Huckel. Und die da unten, der Klimaanlage ist voller Pulle. Bringt alles nichts. Und deswegen haben die da oben mal die Türen geöffnet. Aber ich glaube, das bringt auch nichts.
Roddy, kannst du mal...
1135.
Das bringt ja doch was. Also ein bisschen weniger atmen, ganz ruhig.
Was ist das genau? Der CO2-Level?
Der CO2-Monitor und ein Gerät.
1135, ab wann ist es?
800.
Ab 800 nimmt die Konzentrationsfähigkeit ab. Und nach oben oder nach oben? Nach oben.
Oben ist es schlechter.
Oben ist es schlechter. Also 1200, 1400 sollte man eigentlich schon fast das Gebäude evakuieren. Ich hab mir sagen lassen, es war hier schon 2500.
Wir können hier gleich mal eine URL durchgeben, das machen wir ja immer sehr gerne. co2.no1.at, ein Beitrag unserer österreichischen Freunde.
Du bist ja diskriminierend, nur an der Top-Level-Domain. Vielleicht wollten sie einfach das Add? Also es gibt ziemlich viele coole Top-Level-Domains, zum Beispiel Italien mit IT.
Ich guck erstmal, ob das im Webverzeichnis steht.
Du meinst, noch niemand ist auf die Idee gekommen, österreichische Top-Level-Domains zu verwenden?
Ich geb das jetzt einfach mal ein hier. Wie ist denn? Wenn es schön ist, machen wir das auf dem Game-Up.
Du hast bestimmt gleich so einen Jailbreak dahinter oder so.
Der all deine Bitcoins raubt.
Übrigens finde ich, dass das Internet ganz brauchbar funktioniert.
Gerade so.
Ich bin ja immer noch auf LTE.
Du bist immer noch auf LTE.
Ihr könnt ja mal kurz mich hier mit meinem Apparat mal hier auf den Screen schalten, damit das auch alle irgendwie sehen können.
Auf welcher Seite im Buch bist du jetzt?
Ich blätter die ganze Zeit rum.
Auf den Schirm bitte.
Auf den Schirm.
Es gibt übrigens etliche Hörer, die sich per Twitter mit Rhabarberkuchen melden.
Das war noch mal genau was das Zeichen, wofür?
Sie haben Freak Show gehört und waren noch nie auf unserem, also auf UNSAM, Kongress.
Kannst mal sehen.
Das muss geändert werden.
So, gucke mal hier. Übersicht der letzten 8 Stunden heißt es hier.
Es sieht dramatisch aus.
Ich messe hier mehr.
Upsa, da bricht das HDMI-Signal weg.
Ja, also Sendezentrum leidet unter chronischer Sauerstoffmangelsituation.
Und mangelnder HDMI-Konnektivität.
Was viel wichtiger ist für dich.
Ja, wo ist jetzt mal eine Brose hin?
Hier, schick mal zurück, Huckel. Da kamen schon mal bessere Sachen letztes Jahr.
Hier, ihr da an der Station. Stopf mal wieder in das Gerät.
Ups.
Aber wo...
War es überhaupt schon mal im grünen Bereich?
Wo ist denn?
Nicht wirklich. Ich frage mich jetzt nur gerade, wo ist dieses Messgerät? Ist da eine Information? Achso, hier. Aber ich meine, ist es schon die ganze Zeit hier?
Lass mir da nicht rein. Ja, 1400 jetzt.
Das misst gar nicht.
Das dauert einen Moment.
So schnell ist es eigentlich.
Ja, da kann man es gut erkennen.
Wir können das eh nicht sehen.
Nee, aber stimmt, das lag doch hier auch schon die ganze Zeit auf dem Tisch rum. Das hab ich da irgendwo gesehen. Ja, und was sagt uns das jetzt Ganze? Es wird geatmet.
Ja, und Leute überleben trotzdem. Also...
Ein Wunder.
Apropos überleben. Prinzessin Leia ist tot.
Also so einen Misstun hättest du jetzt nicht in diese Sendung bringen müssen. Warum?
Man kann doch die Leute dann auch hochleben lassen. Das ist doch auch sehr angemessen, dem zu gedenken.
Sollen wir's Carrie nennen?
Ich mein, das... Ja, ich meine, jetzt haben wir uns schon so viel über Star Wars unterhalten.
Ich dachte, mir kann man das ja vielleicht auch mal aufbringen.
Aber meinst du, das ist ein Scheißthema? Jetzt hab ich irgendwie die ganze Sendung gebastelt, oder ist jetzt alles vorbei?
Also ich hoffe ja eigentlich immer noch, dass jetzt so... Also da ja 2016 so...
Ausklinkt langsam.
Ausklinkt und schon viele Leute abgemeldet hat im Laufe des Jahres.
Ausgeklinkt hat.
Die haben sich ausgelockt.
Uns allen würde jetzt ja eigentlich noch jemand einfallen, der jetzt noch so auf den letzten Metern vielleicht...
Der auch noch gestorben ist.
Also auch noch sich aus...
Also der auch noch sterben könnte.
Ja, da würden mir noch so einige einfallen, die mal irgendwie sterben könnten.
Ja, und zwar Leute, die Sicherheitsfragen erfunden haben.
Aber was ja immer so schön ist...
Wer heißt dein bester Schulfreund?
Wie hieß dein erster Chef? Scheiße, welche meinten die jetzt? Dein erstes Haus hier. War es jetzt der Hase oder war es die Katze? Scheiße.
Welche von den Katzen war es?
Ja, welche, genau. Ich hab die beide gleichzeitig bekommen. So bescheuert.
Habt ihr diesen großartigen Tweet gesehen von Stephen Fry zum Thema Carrie Fisher?
Aber du wirst uns jetzt sicher darüber erzählen.
Und schiebst du das Fenster noch so dahin, dass wir das alle sehen?
Wenn der Zeitpunkt gekommen ist.
Ja, dann lass ihn mal kommen.
Weil du weißt ja auch.
Umso schwächer der Witz, umso mehr Vorbereitung braucht man, damit er trotzdem noch irgendwie halbwegs kommt. Nee, ich fand das einfach nur bemerkenswert, weil es ja nicht so, dass man die Leute jetzt besonders gut kennen würde. Und Stephen Fry war wohl irgendwie so halbwegs bekannt mit ihr und twitterte dann irgendwie dieses Foto von Geburtstagsgeschenken, die Carrie Fisher ihm in den letzten Jahren gemacht hat. Also bemerkenswert, unter anderem eine Jane Austen Action Figure, eine Dick O'Rett Patch, so eine Art Starter Kit.
Also das ist sozusagen so ein nicht Nikotin Patch, sondern so ein Anti-Sex Patch, oder was?
Starter Kit Dick O'Rett Patch. Keine Ahnung, was das jetzt über Stephen Fry aussagt. Und auch dieses schöne Schild mit Come in, wo er kanns, vielleicht dann auch ziemlich straight. Und überhaupt las ich so nach, dass sie ja wohl eine ziemlich coole Sau gewesen ist. Man weiß ja immer nicht so mit den Prinzessinnen, ist das ja immer so eine Sache. Da hat man ja keinen Einblick. Also schon vor allem.
Don't get me started.
Doch.
Wie ist denn so dein Leben mit älteren Prinzessinnen?
Nein, nein, also er hier. Er hat ja abgewinkt. Ich hab mit älteren Prinzessinnen, also ich hab da gar nichts zu melden hier an dieser Stelle.
Ich hab die Frau seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr gesehen. Viel hat man ja von der nicht mitbekommen.
Ja, aber was hat sie dir zum Geburtstag geschenkt?
Mir nichts.
Ich sehe schon, als Star Wars Thema verfängt bei euch überhaupt nicht. Ich guck noch mal nach einer Webseite. Vielleicht haben wir da irgendwie was Schönes.
Was soll das mit dem Rababakun? Du hast da irgendwie echt... Wart ihr schon im Kids-Space?
Und wir haben überlebt.
Warst du da? Und bist du auch mal mit den kleinen Go-Karts auf dieser Rennstrecke, die sie abgeklebt haben, rumgefahren?
Ich fand das sehr charming. Ich war mit Überleben beschäftigt.
Während du da lang gefahren bist?
Oder du konzentriert waren?
Während ich es durchschritten habe.
Ah, weil du sozusagen umrand wurdest.
Also denen müssen die da auf jeden Fall noch was ganz anderes in die Maate tun. Hab ich so das Gefühl.
Müssen sie tun oder haben sie getan?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich beneide dieses Energielevel, was da 24-7 gefühlt auf den Boden gebracht wird.
Genau, geht es auf jeden Fall zur Sache. Es gibt auch irgendwie einen Minecraft-Server. Das ist vielleicht jetzt nichts Besonderes, aber das habe ich jetzt mal so mitbekommen. Sonst wäre ja sonst immer nicht so alles so mit. Aber ich finde es super, was da so für Angebote gemacht wurde. Und auch die von uns, glaube ich, auch. Haben wir das überhaupt angesprochen? Oder waren das nur, war das der andere Podcast? Dass Lego Duplo doch gespendet werden sollte, hatte wohl außerordentliche Erfolge erzielt. Und es gibt da irgendwie so ein geiler Lego Duplo-Wolke, wo auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Dinge entstehen. Also nicht nur diese riesigen Dinger, die gibt es ja auch, sondern halt so das richtige Duplo.
Wie das richtige Duplo?
Nein, das richtige Lego Duplo, das Supersized Lego.
Und was ist das nicht richtige Lego Duplo?
Na, das sind diese überdimensionierten Baukasten, mauerartigen Dinger, die da auch existieren, die auch ganz cool sind.
Sowas gibt es mittlerweile.
Oh ja, sowas gibt es mittlerweile. Ja, da muss ich mal eurer Figur in Kinder Spielzentren.
Kommt schon noch, kommt schon noch.
Das ist ein guter Test, vor allem fürs Gehör.
Du meinst besser als die Subwoofer in der Lounge?
Ja, deutlich. Also das sind Frequenzgänge. Tja, das ist schwierig. Sowas gibt es ja noch positives zu berichten. Kann man über dieses Jahr überhaupt etwas nennenswertes erzählen?
Wir können nur hoffen, dass es besser wird.
Es kann ja nur besser werden.
Bist du sicher?
Nein, leider nicht.
Mit allen Vorträgen, die ich bisher gesehen hab, mir fehlt gerade noch der Vortrag, der mich so positiv in die Zukunft trägt.
Irgendwas ist passiert.
Hab ich das Loch zugestellt?
Dennis, vielleicht sollten wir den CO2 ein bisschen weiter von dem weglegen.
Wo ist der jetzt? Er wädert da rein.
Bei 3500.
Ist das Wasser mit Kohlenseuche?
Vielleicht hab ich aber auch den passenden Vortrag verpasst. Gab's schon einen, der so die Zukunft und alles wird gut.
Du warst doch bei dem Überraschungsgast. Erzähl doch mal.
Aber der Überraschungsgast war ja auch nicht...
Du willst jetzt Märchenstunde oder was?
Nee, ich will Star Trek.
Jetzt erzähl doch mal, das hat doch nicht jeder mitbekommen.
Ich war in einem Vortrag zum NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Edward Snowden war da. Wer hat's gesehen? Er war nicht da, er wurde gestreamt.
Aber es war nicht eingekündigt worden.
Mir war das nicht klar. Plötzlich saß ich da und wartete auf Fragen und Antworten. Und dann sprach er zu uns. Er hat Standing Ovation bekommen, natürlich. Mehrfach. Aber seine Nachricht war jetzt auch, also im Wesentlichen, wir müssen mal den Arsch hochkriegen. Aber weil alles ganz schrecklich ist, und wenn wir den Arsch nicht hochkriegen, wird es noch viel schrecklicher. Oder noch viel schrecklicher als und so weiter. Aber das war halt auch nicht der Talk, der so nach vorne zieht. Der einem glauben machen will, dass 2017 toller wird.
Es geht ja gar nicht mehr um toller. Es geht ja nur um weniger Scheiße. Oder? Das ist doch so das Gefühl, das ich gerade so ein bisschen breit mache.
Das wird bestimmt gut klappen.
Ich meine, ich als Berufsoptimist hab's da ein bisschen einfacher. Weil ich halt immer rechtzeitig gedanklich flüchte und mir das ausreichend schön rede.
Ich bin auch Optimist. Aber es wird schwerer.
Wann steigt denn dann deine Wireless-Kopfhörer-Party? Das soll ja alles besser werden.
Naja, also ich meine, wenn ich den Link kriege von dem Zeug, also das...
Dann ist sie quasi schon organisiert, meinst du?
Dann ist sie schon quasi organisiert. Ja, ist grandios. Ich meine, wir könnten hier sozusagen auf der Sendezentrumsbühne mehrere Podcasts gleichzeitig durchführen, was das für eine Sendungsdichte bringen würde.
Ich glaub, die würden uns ganz schnell abwehnen bei dem Scheiß, den wir erzählen.
Das kann gut sein, weil wenn unsere Farbe dann nicht aufleuchtet, dann ist man nach 5 Minuten raus. Dann macht man halt so ein bisschen, wie nennt man diesen Battle, immer wenn so zwei miteinander verglichen werden, womit Facebook groß geworden ist?
Soundsystem?
Nein, wenn man hier so schöne Menschen oder nicht so hübsche Menschen miteinander vergleicht.
Hot or not, oder was?
Ja, so was, genau.
Gibt es sicherlich auch noch ein paar angenehmere Beispiele, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Aber man macht sozusagen, also könnte man ja auch dann so Podcasts, pot or not.
Die Domäne ist in 5 Minuten weg werden.
Es sind immer noch nicht alle Pot-Witze gemacht.
Find ich gut.
Von welchem Thema sind wir abgekommen? Ach so, von der deprimierenden Zukunft.
Also ich glaub, ich kann das erklären. Kann ich? Scheiße. Also ich glaub, es ist ja so wie im Club. Im Club gibt's nicht so richtig, wie soll ich sagen, so ein Bestrafungssystem. Das heißt, warte, warte, lass mich ausbrennen. Wenn ja bei uns einer Scheiße macht, wir werden eigentlich immer schwer wieder los. Wir werden ihn schwer wieder los. Wenn er erstmal drin ist im Club und er macht Kack, dann so mit Rausschmiss, haben wir das nicht so. Oder wir sagen dann, hör mal auf, Scheiße zu machen, aber da wir ja kein Bestrafungssystem haben, kann er einfach weitermachen und das passiert größtenteils nichts. Bis auf Ausnahmen. Und das ist auf dieser Welt auch so. Weiß ich, so ein Politiker, dem wird gesagt, wir haben Verfassung und alles und die sagen, ja und? Und deswegen wird es nicht besser.
Du willst also ein Bestrafungssystem?
Das hab ich nie gesagt.
So, 3 Strikes für Politiker.
Einen vielleicht, reicht doch.
Ja, aber wo wir gerade so bei, ich meine, ihr kennt euch hier bestimmt, warte mal, this world in data.
Achso, ich dachte Tinder für Politiker.
ourworldindata.org.
Genau, guck mal.
Our world in data ist sozusagen jetzt mal so für die Optimisten unter uns und solche, die es werden wollen. Genau, also ich hab da mal auch einen Podcast zu gemacht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es schon mal erwähnt habe, aber das ist, kennt ihr die Seite? Nein. Our world in data ist so ein Projekt, wo der Max Rosa, der hat halt so angefangen, Studien über alles Mögliche zusammenzutragen, was halt Fortschritte der Welt oder überhaupt Fortläufe der Welt in irgendeiner Form mal wissenschaftlich, hoffentlich korrekt zusammenfasst. Also, Entwicklungen zu allen möglichen Sachen. Man sieht das hier auch schon schön hier in der Headline, also Bevölkerung, Gesundheit, Ernährung, Energie, Umwelt, Technologie, Gleichheit, etc. Business, all diese ganzen Kram, Krieg, Wettbewerb, Terror, Gewalttaten, das volle Programm. Und mit sehr wenigen Ausnahmen, es ist erstaunlich, dass eigentlich alles die ganze Zeit besser wird.
Also, bessere Gewalt, bessere Straftaten, besserer Terror, bessere Kriege, genau.
Nö, also ich meine, wir können uns ja immer was raussuchen hier.
Hupsala, das ist hier alles neu.
Steht da auch, wann der Warp Drive kommt und die Replikatoren?
Was hätten wir denn jetzt hier gerne? Völkervernichtung oder Terrorismus?
Besserer Terrorismus. Viel besser strukturisiert.
Ja, genau. Gucken wir doch mal hier. Terrorismus.
Viel effizienter. Weniger Terroristen mussten sterben bei Attentaten.
Okay, das war jetzt vielleicht nicht so die geile Grafik, die wir hier rausgesucht haben.
Ja, Herr Berufsoptimist, das erklären Sie uns jetzt mal.
Man muss nur lange genug scrollen, bis die Daten dann auch passen.
Nimm doch mal was anderes.
Nimm doch nochmal den Warp Drive oder sowas. Zeitreisen.
Mach mal Education, das ist da bestimmt besser geworden. Wir sind alle schlauer geworden, oder?
Global Rise of Education. Da ist ein Ständchen dran, vielleicht ist das toll. Wir müssen erstmal wieder was laden. Also, believe me, es ist wirklich so, die allermeisten Kenndaten, also so Armut, Zugang zu Nahrung, etc., Bildung und so weiter, ist einfach über teilweise sehr lang aufgezeichnete Zeiträume immer besser geworden. Anzahl der Demokratien auf dieser Welt, zum Beispiel, also mit natürlich unterschiedlichen Abstufungen von, wie demokratisch das denn definiert ist. Es ist überhaupt sehr erstaunlich, wie viele unterschiedlichen Arten von Demokratien es gibt.
Wie viele Russlande Demokratien nennen?
Ich?
Glaube nicht.
Ich guck grad mal.
Aber ist bestimmt einer, oder? So offiziell.
Naja, also ich war, wie gesagt, sehr erstaunt, wie viele unterschiedliche Begriffe oder Unterscheidungen vielmehr es eben da gibt.
So, hier, Democracy. Gucke mal.
90% Demokratien, ne?
Genau, haben wir jetzt sozusagen.
87, leider wieder ein bisschen runtergegangen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die USA da jetzt schon eingepreist ist.
So, Anteil der Weltbevölkerung, der so in Demokratien lebt, geht auch geschmeidig nach oben hier. Und hier haben wir diese schöne Aufstellung. Kann man das irgendwie halbwegs, ich mach's mal noch mal ein bisschen größer hier soweit das hier.
Also Russland ist nicht grün, ne?
Roten ist ne grune, ne, da haben wir jetzt auch nicht mit gerechnet. So, guck mal, das ist jetzt hier so die Weltkarte 2015. Und der extremste Fall ist sozusagen Kolonie. Und Kolonie gibt's jetzt gar nicht mehr. Und im richtigen Sinne ist das hier auch so ein Movie. Ja, genau, hier kann man das nämlich schön sehen. Da hast du also erstmal halbe Welt.
Deutschland, no data, wussten sie nicht, ja.
Na ja, damals war ja dann auch so. Und dann, wir hatten noch hier so eine Milliarde verschiedene Grafschaften und Herzlöge etc. Und dann entwickelt sich das halt immer so weiter. Bei 1916 hört jetzt gerade auf einmal dieses Video auf. Warum auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
2016, 1916, da ist bestimmt auch so ein 100 Jahre Back.
Genau, also hier wird zwischen Kolonie, Autokratie, geschlossene Anokratie, offene Anokratie und Demokratie und No Data unterschieden.
Und das war jetzt dein Versuch uns Optimismus sozusagen.
Ja, ich finde, da ist eine ganze Menge... Na, ihr seid ja auch harte Brocken und schwer zu überzeugen.
Ja, aber ich finde... Das geht doch gar nicht.
Ja, das auch. Nee, natürlich geht es nicht um euch. Es geht an alle. Um uns geht es.
Du wolltest doch da Optimisten draus machen, jetzt zeig doch mal was.
Und wer ist jetzt Optimist von euch?
Geht es euch schon besser?
Wer ist denn so Optimist so?
Wer denkt denn nächstes Jahr ist besser als 2016?
Wir müssen das Thema für unsere Hörer an den Endgeräten auch mal... Wie viele Leute stehen hier rum? Wir haben jetzt ungefähr so, na, ich würde mal sagen...
12.000.
2.300. Und jetzt noch mal die Optimisten. Wer ist unverbesserlicher Optimist? Hände hoch. Das sind schon mal eine ganze Menge. Und ich glaube, unverbesserliche Optimisten sind eine echte Kraft. Sagen wir mal jetzt, machen wir mal so... Ich wäre eigentlich lieber Optimist, aber... Wer hat schon lange... Also das waren jetzt ungefähr die Hälfte.
Du bist Optimist, aber deutlich.
Ja, das ist auch gut. Das ist gut für den Mind und den Breinen. So, wer ist in die nächste Kategorie?
Ich war früher Optimist, aber jetzt sehe ich die Welt klarer.
Oh ja, das ist hier bestimmt sehr populär, oder?
Nee, nee, nur einzelne Hände geben.
Einzelne Hände, okay. Wer würde sich einfach als Pessimisten bezeichnen? Aha, siehst du mal, keiner.
Wer als Realist?
Ach, Realisten, na los, das sind doch die Spitzfindigen. Gibt's aber auch nicht so viele.
Und wer ist beim Congress?
Und jetzt alle melden, die sich noch nicht gemeldet haben.
Genau, also wer könnte mit all diesen Kategorien nichts anfangen?
Ihr lügt doch, das war doch nicht alles vorher.
Ja, die sind einfach alle nicht beteiligungswillig. Aber merkst du was, die Optimisten sind einfach in der Mehrheit.
Jetzt hast du das erste Mal was...
Nee, als Optimisten muss man sich nicht so verstecken. Es ist ja was Positives und so bla bla blub und die Pessimisten denken, ne, das erzähl ich ja keinem.
Das bringt ja jetzt eh nichts, wenn ich mich melde.
Wenn ich mich jetzt melde, dann wird es noch viel schlimmer.
Das ist der State of Denial, weiß schon man, gibt das ja nicht zu. Weil man will es ja eigentlich nicht. Das sind ja die äußeren Umstände, die einen dazu zwingen.
Pessimist und stolz drauf, das wäre auch noch eine Kategorie.
Ich gucke gerade nochmal im Web-Verzeichnis.
Ist das hier so dein random Thema Aufschnapper?
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, in welcher Kategorie ich mal nochmal so blättern konnte. Und irgendwo so zwischen Arbeit und Beruf und Erotik. Es gibt zum Beispiel keine Kategorie Politik in diesem Web-Verzeichnis. Mode und Style.
Von wann ist das denn?
Ah, doch hier Politik und Behörden.
Genau, von wann ist das denn? Frisch?
Ach, das ist bestimmt top aktuell.
Gute Frage.
Steht bestimmt vorne im Dings hier.
Auflage vom... Ich glaube, das ist genau diese Art Buch, wo man das am besten nicht reinschreibt.
Das soll ja zeitlos sein.
Copyright 1998 bis 2016. Ernsthaft.
Die drucken das immer noch?
Ja, aber es ist von 98 wahrscheinlich.
Ist ja egal, die Leute, die das kaufen, die wissen das eh nicht.
Die haben nur die Sachen gelöscht, die da nicht mehr laufen. Guck einmal an hier. Politik und Behörden fängt an mit Abgeordneten-Watch. Das ist doch für den Optimisten schon mal genau das Richtige. Netzpolitik-Org. Ach, die sind doch gekauft hier. Fragt den Staat.
Das ist repräsentativ.
Vielleicht findest du doch die Freak Show, stimmt's?
Unter welcher Kategorie?
Haus und Garten.
Unterhaltung.
Ah, warte mal, ganz auf dem... Ah, Presse-Stimmen.
Im Chat wird gerade uns zugerufen.
Genau.
Das Web-Adressbuch für Deutschland. Das versuch ich jetzt auch mal mit dieser Radiostimme. Das Web-Adressbuch für Deutschland präsentiert die besten und wichtigsten Internetadressen zu über 1000 Themen auf einen Blick. Ein großer Vorteil gegenüber Suchmaschinen. Man muss nicht erst ein konkretes Stichwort im Kopf haben, sondern kann auch neue Webseiten zu Themen entdecken, an die man gar nicht gedacht hätte. Ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch so ein Feature, was mir in Web-Browse fehlt. Ich meine, die heißen ja Browser, aber so richtig blättern kann man damit nicht.
Du bist auch ein alter Yahoo-User, ne?
Ne, ich finde nur so dieses so, dieses so...
Durchblättern, was so... Brauchst du auch so deinen Daily Random Link?
Presse-Stimmen.
Geniale Tipps aus dem Internet. Münchner Melkur. Die Computer-Bild meint, blättern und finden eine Alternative für alle, die von Google-Suchergebnissen frustriert sind. Hört zu! Tatsächlich enthält das Buch viele Geheimtipps, die Suchmaschinen wie Google nicht gleich als erstes aufführen.
Ja, die doch auch nicht. Ist dann auf Seite 305.
Genau, zum Beispiel artplants.de. Über 1500 Kunstpflanzen, Kunstbäume, Kunstpalmen und Kunstblumen. Zudem Zubehör wie Pflegeprodukte oder Vasen. Hättest du das jetzt mit Google gefunden?
Klar.
Nicht, weil ich gesucht hätte.
Hamburger Abendblatt. Statt sich durch unzählige Seiten zu klicken, reicht ein Blick unter dem gewünschten Stichwort, um die richtige Webseite zu finden. Web-Seite. Dresdener Morgenpost. Dieser Band sollte immer griffbereit beim Desktop liegen.
Die Betonung liegt auf Desktop.
Wenn hier rot ist, ist das schlecht, ne?
Ja, sehr schlecht.
Ist schon rot?
Roddy, deine Lebenserfahrung ist...
Erwartung ist ein Rot.
Drei Monate, vielleicht sechs, wenn du Glück hast.
Der CO2-Sensor macht alle nervös.
Der war doch von dir.
Ich hab da vorhin reingeblasen, meinst du?
Weiß nicht.
McLife, ja? Wir als allgemein als...
Opfer?
Apple Podcast eingestufte Unterhaltungssendung mit großer Themenbreite meint, es müssen nicht immer Suchmaschinen sein, wie dieses erfolgreiche Buch seit 19 Jahren beweist.
PC-Magazin.
Die meinen das nicht wirklich ernst, oder? Du!
Ich meine, das sind Presse-Stimmen. Das ist nicht so Podcast-Stimmen oder so.
Jetzt sind's auch Podcast-Stimmen.
Dann musst du bei PC-Magazin weiterlesen, weil jetzt wird's ja spannend.
Nee, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Also ganz ehrlich, man macht sich ja leicht lächerlich über sowas, ne? Aber mal ehrlich.
Es gibt nur zwei Einträge zur Weltverschwörung.
Welche?
allmystery.de und weltverschwörung.de Die dürfen wir aber jetzt nicht eintippen, oder?
Die Pressestimmen, zwei fehlen noch.
Nee, du machst die Pressestimmen. Ich trage nur einzelne.
An die Vorauswahl der Redaktion kommen die Algorithmen von Google und Co.
nicht ran.
Das finde ich auch so interessant. Google und Co. Das liest man auch irgendwie immer wieder, ne? Ja, wer ist denn Co.?
Gibt's Alta Wister noch?
Metacrawler.
Nee, es klingt auch so Google und Co. Das klingt so wie Google und seine Gang. So klingt das. Selbst Online-Experten werden beim Schmökern so manchen Web-Tipp finden, den sie bis dahin noch nicht kannten. Wir können auch mal eine Umfrage machen. Gibt's hier irgendwelche Online-Experten?
Ich glaube, die haben sich auch als Optimisten gemeldet.
Genau.
Das ist das deutsche Internet. Das kann man so sagen. Da ist auch alles drin. Hier auch Jugend-Mädchen, eine Community speziell für Mädchen. Hier können Mädchen eine eigene Anziehpuppe oder die des Lieblingsstars gestalten.
Leute, echt.
Das sind doch die mit den Pferden, oder?
Ich geb's auf.
Vielleicht sollten wir selber meinen Web-Magazin rausbringen.
Das fände ich in der Tat sehr viel spannender.
Du meinst einen Blog?
Nein, unsere Lieblings-Webseiten.
Genau, so dass Freak Show Web-Nachschlage hilft.
Auch im Print.
Muss man mal gesehen haben.
Na klar.
Meine Lieblings-Start-Webseite, die ich in jedem Browser konfiguriere, ist ja auch blank.org.
Da kommt die leere Seite.
Das ist mein erster Tipp in dieser Hinsicht. blank.org. blank.org? Ja, und die Seite ist auch überwiegend blank, aber in der Mitte, wenn man ganz genau hinguckt, ist ein roter Pixel. Auf den kann man klicken, wenn man ganz gelangweilt ist. Und wenn man da draufklickt, dann... Weil es kommt eine Webseite mit kleiner Schrift, die dich wirklich nochmal...
Blank is beautiful.
Die dich quasi nochmal fragt, ob du jetzt wirklich so gelangweilt bist, dass du nochmal da draufklickst und hoffst, dass du erlöst wirst.
Das ist aber nicht der Nachfolger von Goatzi.
Könnte aber sein.
Aber klick mal.
Es wird immer größer.
Es hört irgendwann auf. Du musst wirklich wollen.
More to come soon. Jetzt muss man da wieder draufklicken.
Und von da wirst du jetzt...
Das ist was für die Pessimisten, oder?
Ne, tatsächlich verbirgt sich hinter diesen Links jeweils weitere... Also wie das Web ursprünglich mal gedacht war. Man folgt halt diesen Links und man klickt immer weiter. Und irgendwie nach einer halben Stunde, wenn man dieses blank.org immer weiterklickt, dann landet man definitiv an einem Ort, wo man dachte nie gewesen sein zu wollen.
Ist das der vierte Link?
Alle Links führen...
An diesen Ort.
An beliebige Punkte der Matrix.
Du kannst mich jetzt ja sozusagen noch stoppen.
Ich würde sagen Cliffhanger. Jeder probiert das einfach selber aus und berichtet dann uns Twitter oder in den Blogkommentaren von der Freak Show, wo sie gelandet sind. Aber blank.org ist tatsächlich so ein Klassiker, den nicht viele kennen. Hand hoch, wer kannte blank.org?
Keiner.
Online-Experte. Das ist mein erster Web-Tipp jetzt.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an einen alten Sport, den wir damals in Kaufhäusern betrieben haben. Damals, als das der einzige Ort war, wo man an einen Computer rankam. Jetzt kommt wieder so Old-Fahrt-Material.
Auto-Exec-Bad löschen und...
Da gab es auch noch keine Auto-Exec-Bad.
Nein, C64.
C64, genau.
Weil die C64 standen ja immer so offen rum. Und...
Mussten wir dein Basic aushalten. Und die Schleife, die du dann probiert hast.
Ja, genau. Wir haben dann so Pranks programmiert. Das heißt, wir haben Programme geschrieben, die dann genauso aussahen wie der normale Startscreen. Und wenn dann irgendwelche Kunden sich das erste Mal an diesen Computer herantrauten und eine Taste drücken, passierten immer ganz grausame Dinge. Und wurden dann irgendwie erschreckt. Dann haben wir uns dann immer so hinter den, ja, haben uns dann immer so versteckt und das angeschaut. Das macht man halt so allmacht als Jugendlicher. Ich mein, das war, wir hatten ja nichts. Ja, macht ihr das mal klar.
Nicht mal Blue-Screens.
82.
Nichts.
Kein Internet.
Da wurde ich gerade geboren.
Huckel wurde gerade geboren.
Ja, wir hatten ja nichts. Wir haben ja Huckel.
Nicht mal Huckel hatten wir. So, aber so ein bisschen sowas wie blank.org hat es halt auch, weil wenn du das jetzt Leuten einfach so einstellst, dann so, mein Pixel ist kaputt. Ja, und dann noch drauf rumklicken, dann können halt Dinge passieren.
Einer meiner Lieblingskollegen-Scherze ist ja immer, einen Screenshot von ihrem Desktop zu machen, und das als Hintergrundbild einzurichten und alle Ordner dazu verstecken sozusagen, um dann zu beobachten, wie sie zu ihrem Rechner zurückkehren und festzustellen, dass es offensichtlich einen Freeze gab und jetzt die nächste Amtshandlung ein Reboot wäre, um dann genau wieder in den gleichen Screens zu kommen. Es sind die einfachen Freuden. Was ist denn, habt ihr denn noch irgendeine Webseite, die ihr noch nie anderen Leuten empfohlen habt, die ihr aber gelegentlich, also so eine ganz obskure, so ganz hinten in der Ecke?
Nicht so auf die Schnelle.
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Windows 93.net. Das ist doch ein Mac-Podcast.
Das ist natürlich so ein bisschen gefährlich, wenn man jetzt einfach irgendwelche URLs nennen lassen, weil man weiß ja nie, was dabei draus kommt.
Aber wenn das jetzt schlecht ist... Ach, das Ende des Internets.
Aber ob das wirklich das Ende ist?
Ich hatte früher ja mal... Mir kamen ja mal so... Ich hab so verhinderte Kunstprojekte, wo ich ehrlich gesagt furchtbar traurig bin über jedes einzelne, was ich nicht realisiert habe. Ich muss gleich noch mal ein bisschen kramen. Aber ich hatte irgendwie relativ früh so die Idee eines Online-Müll-Eimers, wo man einfach so seine Daten entsorgen konnte.
Online?
Ja, also du löschst halt was.
So wie diese Schredder...
Und sie haben Ipoh gemacht oder wie auch immer und heißen jetzt hier Dropbox?
Da sammelt man dann halt einfach so... Es war halt Kunst, also das muss sozusagen... Ich war mir jetzt nicht mehr so ganz so sicher, in welchem Jahr das war, in Abhängigkeit davon, muss man ja dann immer so ein bisschen justieren, was irgendwie cool ist und was nicht. Weil manchmal sagt man ja so Dinge voraus oder findet sie dann so total lustig und dann später wird einem so gewahr auf Weier. Also ich weiß noch, als das allererste Mal im CCC so von außen die Anfrage kam, ja sagen sie mal, sie kennen sich doch aus, kann man denn per E-Mail sich ein Virus einfangen? Und wir alle so, das geht nie! Weil wer würde denn auf die Idee kommen, an ein E-Mail ein Programm anzuhängen, was dann auch noch automatisch ausgeführt wird? Und dann haben die das alles implementiert und dann sind diese ganzen furchtbaren Dinge dann auch immer noch entstanden, wo man sich halt vorher überhaupt nicht vorstellen konnte, dass es so ist. Und ich glaube, genauso ist das jetzt hier auch so mit unserem aktuellen Pessimismus, dass hier ganze Zeit einfach so Dinge passieren, von denen wir irgendwie gar nicht dachten, dass es irgendwie passieren kann.
Das ist schlimmer als unsere Vorstellung.
Ja, weil wir sind eigentlich alle Optimisten und verbessern dich geradezu. Guck mal, was haben wir denn immer postuliert? Ja, Internet, wenn das dann mal kommt und alle sich austauschen können, das ist ja eine Happy Family, dann gehen die Ideen von A nach B und alle denken so, oh ja, warum ich denn da noch nicht drauf gekommen bin? Das ist ja eine hervorragende Gedanke, da könnten wir ja alle in Frieden miteinander und so.
Aber wenn alle miteinander und so die Krankheiten, du weißt schon.
Ja, das Problem ist halt nur, dass irgendwie alle Leute, die mal wirklich ihre Ideen austauschen sollten, immer so, ah, Internet, lass mich in Frieden, ich hab irgendwie mein Buch.
Mein Almanach.
Und die Leute, an die wir nicht gedacht haben, die sind jetzt irgendwie da und tauschen ihre Ideen aus und schon ist die Kacke am Dampfen. Das ist das Problem. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt halt eigentlich irgendwie gegensteuern. Also irgendwas müssen wir machen.
Das hat Edward Snowden auch gesagt.
Du musst halt den Arsch hochkriegen.
Ja, das hat er auch gesagt.
Ja, aber jetzt sitzen wir hier, ne? Und Roddy auch noch auf dem Einhorn.
Roddy, du sagst irgendwie gar nichts. Bist du eigentlich schon betrunken?
Sein Mikro ist nicht an.
Soweit ich weiß nicht wieso, wollte ich noch was trinken.
Was hast du denn dabei?
Die Freak Show Ultras haben uns...
Vielleicht wird es ja doch noch lustig.
Die Freak Show Ultras.
Ich wollte ja jetzt nicht mehr so viel besaufen. Ach so, da fällt mir eigentlich...
Der vom letzten Jahr, der war so übel.
Mexikaner? Wir werden doch noch betrunken. Aber wir haben keine Glä...
Doch.
Lasst mich raus.
Bisschen Luft für das Einhorn wäre auch gut.
Hier, füll mal ein bisschen ein.
Geil, Mexikaner.
Guck mal, was ich hier am Info-Tresen bekommen habe. Und so haben sie mir gesagt, dass wäre eigentlich das Original-Design hier für den Kongress gewesen. Können wir das irgendwo in die Kamera halten? Wo ist der Kameramann?
Wo ist der Kameramann? Dann mach mal hier Fotobus an oder sowas.
Irgendwo ranhalten.
Mit dem guten deutschen Teenage.
Fotobus. Hier, näher, so.
Und jetzt da auf den Schirm.
Achso, warte mal, wir müssen das, äh, sorry.
Hier ist noch Windows 93, das war ja jetzt nicht so unterhaltsam.
Da muss man bestimmt klicken, deswegen.
Da muss man bestimmt klicken, das mach ich aber jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht gibt's zuerst mal einen.
Das könnt ihr dann zu Hause machen.
Und jetzt, äh, jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt. Wo ist meine Maus? Hier. Wo ist meine Maus?
Ich krieg die Maus, ich krieg die Maus.
So, ich bin onscreen.
Fullscreen.
Geht das?
Dein Einsatz.
Fullscreen, kannst du das nicht größer machen?
Äh, gute Frage.
Ja, also.
So hier.
Und ist jetzt doppelt gespiegelt.
Angeblich soll...
Das ist geil.
Die umgedrehte Schrift, die nicht umgedreht ist, ist natürlich jetzt wieder umgedreht und dann heißt es MROVSKROV. MROVSKROV.
Großartig.
Auf dem Essay.
Was hat er eigentlich da am Kopf? Ein Pfeil im Kopf?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ein Pinsel oder so.
Ein Wolf. Was ist das? In einem Hoodie.
Mit Pfeil im Kopf.
Wenn du diese Botschaft irgendwie von hinten liest, dann könnte sie...
Um mit 66,6 Umdrehungen pro Minute gespielt werden.
Gefährliche Botschaften enthalten. Emrovskroff. Das ist jetzt sozusagen unser Codewort. Ihr könnt ja mal versuchen, das irgendwo an so einem Ding einzugehen. Ach so, das ist ja bisher nicht eifernumerisch.
Gibt's am Info-Tresen für 2,50? Das ist hier zum Aufbügeln. Das ist jetzt hier Qualitätsware.
Emrovskroff.
Für die Hackerkutte.
Mexikaner.
Das wär's eigentlich noch. Du hast so die richtigen Podcast-Fans, die mit so einer Jeans-Weste rumlaufen und von jedem Podcast das Logo so draufgestickt haben. Und dann zu den Live-Events gehen und Neues einsammeln.
Aber dann bitte mit Schal.
Wir müssen mal echt an unserem Merchandising arbeiten.
Da sind wir eigentlich ziemlich weit hinten.
Das haben wir nicht nötig.
Ist eher Faulheit, ehrlich gesagt. Ein bisschen Verpeiltheit, um genauer zu sein.
Also langsam sitze ich hier ganz auf dem Boden. Aber das macht nichts.
Dein Einhorn entweicht die Luft oder was?
Das ist nicht mein Einhorn. Das ist das Einhorn von den Podcast-Party-Nen.
Wie hieß es noch gleich?
Clemens.
Clemens, genau.
Oder Carrie.
Das hat mehrere Namen.
Oder Timme.
Clemens Fischer nennen wir es.
Es gibt eine Luftpumpe auch.
Clemens Fischer. Was für ein romantischer Name für ein Einhorn.
Prost.
Stößchen auf die Zukunft.
Auf den Berufsoptik. Hast du schon getrunken?
Huckel schummelt schon wieder.
Huckel hat das irgendwo hingegossen.
Nee, nee.
Ist ein geiles Zeug.
Sehr würzig.
Wenn beim Inder nicht scharf genug ist, dann macht man sich das da rein.
Kann ich den Foto-Boost wieder ausmachen?
Von wem war das?
Von den Freak Show Ultras.
Die wollen uns umbringen.
Nee, Mexikaner ist super. Mexikaner kommt gleich nach Jägermeister.
Aber letztes Jahr war das nicht so scharf.
Das Hamburger Mundfeuerwerk.
Oder ich war...
Ist aber Klassik, ich weiß nicht, wie hot ist.
Gibt es hot auch noch?
War so eine Vermutung.
Hot or not? Mundfeuerwerk...
Hier steht er sicher.
Mundfeuerwerk kann breit machen und führt zu schärfer Reiz auf der Zunge.
Was steht hier drauf?
Passt.
So wie die Freak Show.
Kann auch breit machen.
Hast du eigentlich unsere Sendungsnummer angekündigt?
Ja.
Und? Nee, hast du nicht? Welche Nummer?
190.
Wann machen wir die Vorstellungsrunde?
Hatten wir eigentlich schon mal eine Fragestunde?
Ich war vorhin schon dabei, zu erklären, wer alles nicht da ist. Das ist so gut gelungen. Dann kam Clemens trotzdem wieder dazwischen. Nein, natürlich haben wir uns vorgestellt. Wir haben uns, wie der Nerd sagt, implizit vorgestellt. Man kann sich implizit und man kann sich explizit vorstellen. Und das ist auch sehr hilfreich. Ich finde, implizites Vorstellen ist auch sehr freundlich. Weil ihr kennt ja alle dieses Verpeilteilsproblem, wenn man um den Kongress rumläuft, und dann wieder so, oh Gott, doller Gesicht, doller Name und dann so irgendwie select from where.
Du meinst, wenn sich beide treffen, beide wissen nicht mehr, wie der andere heißt, und dann kurz sagen, ja und, wie findest du das? Ja, wir sehen uns später als Clashbook und dann sehen sie sich genau ein Jahr später erst wieder.
Nee, ich finde, man kann den Leuten nicht unbedingt immer zumuten, dass sie einen erkennen und zugeordnet bekommen, weil man das ja auch von sich selbst kennt, dass man das immer nicht so kann. Und wenn man dann halt in so einer Situation ist, dann kann man dann schon versuchen, das sozial auszugleichen, indem man dann zum Beispiel so ein bisschen verklemmt in so einer dritten Person von sich redet. Ich geh zur Bar und denk mir noch, ey Timmer, jetzt ein Mexikaner.
Ach, ich dachte so wie die anonymen Hacker. Mein Name ist Roddy und ich, nein.
Dann musst du irgendwie in Geständnis kommen jetzt.
Ja, das Dumme an implizit ist halt, ne?
Sieht übrigens ganz schön albern aus, jetzt wo das Einhorn die ganze Zeit Luft verliert. Du könntest natürlich jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen versuchen, drauf zu reiten oder so.
Das ist privat.
Hast du ein Verhältnis zu Einhörnern? Also ich meine, gib dir das was? Verbindest du was mit Einhörnern?
Hat dir das Einhorn was gegeben?
Ich mag das Einhorn.
Du magst das Einhorn, das ist sehr schön.
Ich hab's auch gleich auf meine Amazon-Wunschliste getan. Ernsthaft?
Natürlich.
Was kostet das?
Guck halt nach.
Aber hast du die entsprechenden Räumlichkeiten? Würdest du dein Bett rausschmeißen und dafür dann auf dem Einhorn?
Mein Bett ist groß genug, das Einhorn kann mit ins Bett.
Ach ja, wie romantisch. Das Bild krieg ich nie wieder aus dem Kopf.
Roddy und sein süßes Einhorn. Warum ist das nicht pink? Obwohl hier ist es bunt.
Da?
Ach Mensch, das ist doch hier alles total überflüssig. Wollen wir noch aufhören oder wollen wir irgendwas interessantes erzählen?
Hast du denn noch was? Ich?
Ja, ich muss immer liefern. Ich sag euch immer so, lasst mal eine Sendung machen und dann so, ja, können wir schon machen. Aber so vorbereiten ist nicht.
Ich hab was genötet.
Ja.
Oh jetzt, Roddy wacht auf. Roddy rettet jetzt die Sendung.
Na ja, du hast was gelötet.
Na das heißt, wie heißt denn das? Ardu Touch Synthesizer.
Es wird gelb, es wird gelb.
Was heißt das?
Leute verlassen das Gebäude.
Die Luft ist besser.
Der CO2-Sensor. Na das ist so ein Ardu Inu ähnliches Teil mit so...
Soll das ein Klavier sein?
Ja, mit so Klaviertasten. Ein Strom-Lautsprecher-Einschalter und so... Ich zieh jetzt mal hier den Stecker raus von dem blauen Kabel. Man steckt den hier ein. Schauen wir mal.
So, und jetzt wird der Regler wieder hochgezogen.
Achso, jetzt muss ich noch einschalten.
Was hast du damit gemacht?
Ich hab die grüne Leuchttiode kaputt gemacht und dann eine weiße geschnort unten im Hackcenter. Nochmal vielen Dank, wer auch immer mehr die gegeben hat.
Das musst du unten in der Lounge testen, der Bass.
Auf dem Kopfhörer ist er gut.
Der Subwoofer wird Dinge auf dem Boden anfangen zu bewegen.
Bleibt noch gut.
Das ist ganz cool.
Das ist jetzt mit Arduino. Das ist kein SID von C64.
Das ist ATMEGA 328P. Wir spielen mal was.
Kannst du Klavier spielen?
Nö.
Hast du das hier auf dem Congress gelötet?
Den hab ich vorhin hier.
Probier's mal mit Multitouch.
Kann er nicht, ne?
Nee, ich glaub, das ist homophon. Ach so, und irgendwann stürzt er ab.
Sendungstitel.
Da waren schon so einige dabei.
Das war's schon?
Aber schön.
Hat doch Klang gemacht.
Schöner Ausklang.
Das kann man unten erwerben und dann kann man all diese Bauteile da drauflöten.
Und die grüne LED?
Ja, wenn man die nicht kaputt macht.
Wie hast du die kaputt gemacht? Zu heiß gelötet?
Ich hab die grüne erst dahin gelötet, wo die blaue sein sollte. Und dann hab ich sie versucht wieder auszulöten und dabei ist sie kaputt gegangen. Aber ich war zu verplant.
Was wünschen wir uns denn fürs neue Jahr? Also abgesehen jetzt von dem Optimismus und der allgemeinen Weltrettung.
Noch mehr?
Hast du Wünsche?
Ja, noch mehr Mexikaner.
Das geht noch dieses Jahr.
Irgendwas mit Holz.
Das wär jetzt deine Gelegenheit gewesen.
Na ja, du hast ja schon die großen Kaninchen aus dem Stall geholt, ne? Mit Weltfrieden und was war das andere? Alles wird besser?
Ich glaube, es ist ein Wünsche, ich bin Optimist, da bin ich irgendwie unverbesserlich.
Das ist schlimm, aber damit müsst ihr klarkommen jetzt.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht wünscht er ja irgendwas für unser Format. Wohin es so gehen soll, was wir zur 200. Sendung machen sollen.
Mehr Einhörner.
Roddy, du bist irgendwie monohomo...
Homothematisch.
Homothematisch, genau.
Sendung müssen wir Party machen. Ja?
Das finde ich allerdings auch. Und Haus abbrennen.
Wenn wir diese Kopfhörer kriegen, wäre das ein Incentive.
Kopfhörer-Party.
Ich bin dagegen. Ich will mich mit Leuten unterhalten.
Das kannst du ja auch.
Wieso? Sind an den Kopfhörern auch Hetsys?
Nein, ich muss...
Ich muss noch mal darauf zurückkommen, weil... Das war jetzt nicht so, dass da keine soziale Interaktion war, weil in diesem Raum war es still. Aber es gab natürlich trotzdem eine Bar und Leute, die halt nicht tanzten. Nur die Leute, die tanzten, hatten Kopfhörer auf und eingeschaltet. Aber wenn du halt keinen Bock auf Tanzen hast, bist du halt an die Bar gegangen und da war es halt total leise.
Ja, weil keiner was gesagt hat.
Und da konnte man sich halt wunderbar auch darüber unterhalten, welcher Farbe jetzt gerade nachgetanzt hat.
Also so den Stupid Small Talk und die Awkward Silence sind da voll ausgeprägt sozusagen.
Awkward Silence ist da default.
Man muss das weiter denken. Guck mal, wir sind ja Nerds. Das heißt, man sammelt natürlich erst mal diese Informationen. Wie viele Kopfhörer sind jetzt gerade auf welche Farbe eingeschaltet? Und das ist dann immer so eine, dann über die Zeit hast du dann eine entsprechende Skala. Man könnte ja dann auch sagen, wann auch immer eine Quelle, das muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt Musik sein, wann auch immer eine Quelle quasi für einen Mindestzeitraum dann Popularität gewonnen hat, also die Mehrheit.
Aber bringt das so eine Party vorwärts?
Mann, das muss man doch erstmal ausprobieren! Was ist denn das immer für eine skeptische Scheiße?
Genau, man muss auch mal ausprobieren.
Immer dieses Internet, wozu brauche ich denn das Computer? Ja wo bleibt denn da der optimistische Blick?
Ich kann ja in die Zukunft gucken, da sehe ich doch, das macht genau eine Viertelstunde lang Spaß und dann ist das langweilig.
Das weißt du doch überhaupt nicht!
Ich kenn mich doch.
Das hast du wahrscheinlich von allem schon mal behauptet. Du hast aber nicht immer Recht behalten.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist die aufregendste Viertelstunde des Jahres.
Ich hab mich auch schon mit Sachen beschäftigt, wo er am Anfang dachte so...
War länger als eine Viertelstunde, stimmt schon.
Ja, aber ich hab auch ein paar andere Sachen mehr angeschaut. Ich weiß noch, wie ihr mich alle angeguckt habt, weil ich mit meinem ersten Podcast in den Club reingekommen und dann so, hier guckt mal, ist ganz toll, irgendwie spür ich das mal vor. Und alle so... Dann gibt's sicherlich was von Radio-Farmen.
Und das war wirklich so, ich kann mich an den Tag erinnern, als Tim in den Club gelaufen ist und gemeint hat, ich will jetzt nur noch Podcasts machen und alle so da saßen so... Na dann, viel Spaß!
Dieser Club war noch nie modern.
Das bedeutet gar nichts.
Ich zähl mir mit diesem 1 Kilo XML-Buch im Club rumgelaufenes Wochenlang.
Ja, das kommt mir auch bekannt vor.
Und hat sich weitergebracht.
Ja.
Und nicht nur XML, XSLT war auf jeden Fall auch da mit dabei.
Fucking Reddit!
So viel Sport hast du noch nie gemacht mit dem 1 Kilo, oder?
Abgesehen davon, dass es zwei echt sehr gute Bücher waren, die ich wirklich sehr intensiv gelesen habe.
Und hast du auch ein XSLT-Predigt bekommen?
Äh, ne, ich bin bestimmt immer geflüchtet vorher.
Aber XSLT war auf jeden Fall auch ein... war schon heiß. Für eine Viertelstunde.
Die Chaos Radio Webseite ist heute noch XSLT und das läuft immer noch, obwohl ich da irgendwie null Maintenance seit Jahren gemacht habe.
Und jetzt die spannende Preisfrage fürs Publikum. Wer von euch hat schon mal XSLT angewandt? Hunderte!
Davon gehört?
Und wer davon freiwillig?
Und wer hat überhaupt keine Ahnung, was XSLT ist?
Wer hat sich jetzt dreimal gemeldet? Ich hab's genau gesehen.
Hausaufgabe zur nächsten Sendung, ihr müsst das rausfinden.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Es gibt halt einfach, es gibt schon so Perlen, da muss man halt auch gegen den Mainstream auch angeschwommen kommen. Ich meine, nur weil jetzt alle Java programmieren, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie eine geile Nummer ist. Oder?
Das würde ich voll und ganz unterschreiben.
Ja, siehst du mal, ne? Und vor allem sag das mal Java programmieren. Bist du also auf eine sehr kleine Minderheit, gucken die sich alle mit so einem beschämten Blick dann so an, so ja, wir machen das ja in der Firma.
Ich hab das halt auf der Uni gelernt. Sagen die ich, ich war ja nicht.
Ja, so was, genau, wir hatten ja nichts.
Genau, 64er, Java.
Genau, genau, das ist das Ding. Und deswegen muss man sich dagegen durchsetzen und muss dann halt auch in der Minderheiten-Position auch standhaft bleiben. Und dann ist das halt auch erfüllend. Also ich fand diese XML-XSLT-Nummer, das hat mich einfach total gekickt.
Ich weiß.
Nimm doch noch einen Schluck Mexikana.
Aber wo waren wir denn gerade stehen geblieben? Wir waren doch vorher noch bei irgendwas...
Zukunft und Technologie und...
Wir wollten das 2017, was wir da so erwarten.
Ah ja, genau. Was hast du denn für Wünsche?
Keine Ahnung. Gutes Wetter wär schon gar nicht schlecht.
XSLT setzt sich durch.
Nein, wir waren bei der Kopfhörer-Party und wir waren bei den Statistiken. Und dass man diesen Ding positiv aufgeschlossen gegenüber sein muss. Und ich sage einfach, erst mal machen...
Aber kannst du das nicht vorausziehen, dass das nicht lange spannend ist? Okay, anders, weil wir ja Umfragen machen. Wer von euch ist der der Meinung, dass das länger spannend ist als eine Party lang?
Das würde ja erst mal vollkommen ausreichen.
Das sind jetzt schon die Antworten oder überlegt ihr noch?
Bisher meldet sich noch niemand.
You've got no fucking evidence, man.
Der hat euch gerade beleidigt.
Nein, man muss das einfach mal alles ausprobieren. Sonst ist es doch nicht gut.
Ja, kann man ja auch.
Dieser ganze Kongress ist ein einziges Ausprobieren.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, wenn sich alle sagen, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wenn ich das zusammenbaue, weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht, ob mich das weiterbringt.
Das hab ich nicht gesagt. Das hast du jetzt umgedeutet. Aber LEDs am Kopfhörer, finde ich...
Es geht doch nicht um die LEDs. Es geht um die fucking Kommunikation.
Aber die hab ich auch auf einer normalen Party.
Es ist ein Gradmesser für dynamische Bewegung einer sozialen Gruppe.
Ja, ich weiß, du stehst ja auch statt.
Die du dann wiederum als Eingabe benutzt. Und damit hast du sozusagen einen Aufschaukelungsmoment. Du kannst eine Feedback-Schleife, eine soziale Feedback-Schleife erzielen.
Du musst jetzt noch Machine Learning sagen.
Für die drei Details ist vielleicht ganz cool. Das ist sozusagen die sozialen, menschlichen, humanoiden, homophonen Systeme, die beeinflussen sich sozusagen automatisch gegenseitig in Echtzeit.
Was ist das?
Und dann passieren unglaubliche Sachen.
Was ist denn das? Tim will ja auch schon immer, seit ich ihn kenne, seine Meinung parametrisieren. Das war eine der ersten Meetings, glaube ich, den ich bei gewohnt habe zum Congress, wo es so um Content-Meetings ging und das PentaBuff, also unser ursprüngliches Planungssystem, ja. Und da war auf jeden Fall auch schon der Wunsch der parametrisierten Meinung. Ganz präsent.
Ja, wir sind nicht weit gekommen. Doch, ich bin sehr weit gekommen, aber der Rest ist ja dann nicht mitgelaufen. Also ich war ja schon ganz weit vorn.
Oder ganz weit hinten.
Ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, dass das alles durchaus überprüfenswert wäre. Und man muss... Ehrlich gesagt, also ich bin... Es gibt hier wirklich eine ganze Menge geile Sachen. Aber wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass wir hier softwaretechnisch schon die Gilde und ganz weit vorn wären, da gehe ich nicht mit.
Spreche jetzt etwa vom Tickel?
Nee, ich rede von allem. Also dafür, dass wir uns so viel mit Software beschäftigen und so viel mit Systemen beschäftigen, gibt es zwar an sich ganz gute Ergebnisse, aber gemessen an dem, was ich mir auch nur so im Ansatz vorstellen könnte, was man eigentlich erzielen könnte, ist da einfach noch eine ganze Menge zu gehen. Also man gibt sich schon doch teilweise recht früh zufrieden für meinen Geschmack.
Aber du hast ja das Coden schon lange aufgegeben.
Na ja, Gott, also ich meine, ich beschäftige mich immerhin...
Noch mit Lisp.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob man sich noch mit Lisp beschäftigt, sondern ob man sich schon mit Lisp beschäftigt.
Und außerdem, er macht mich wahnsinnig. Leute, wirklich.
Aber eigentlich dafür, dass du alleine bist, kommst du ja ganz gut klar gegen drei Leute. Jetzt hier so...
Ja, mich kriegt er eh nicht umgepustet. Ich weiß ja, dass ich recht hab. Und das ist das entscheidende Ding. Also man kann halt nicht aufhören. Man muss einfach immer ein bisschen Zukunft gestalten. Heißt halt auch, darüber nachdenken. Und da eine...
Und Forderungen formulieren.
Ja genau, man muss halt auch ausprobieren. Man kann ja auch scheitern. Scheitern ist ja jetzt sozusagen nichts schlechtes. Scheitern ist super. Weil Scheitern heißt, man hat es zumindest probiert. Aber wenn man sich hinsetzt und sagt so... Mexikaner.
Dann wird da nichts draus.
Ich finde das ein bisschen zu schwarz und weiß gesehen. Es gibt noch Wahrheiten dazwischen.
Kann schon sein.
Prove me wrong.
Nicht alles, was nach einer schlechten Idee klingt, muss ausprobiert werden.
Ach ihr alten Miesmacher. Ich hab euch trotzdem lieb. Wollen wir die Sendung noch optimistisch zu Ende führen?
Wenn du das hinkriegst.
Du bist doch schon betrunken.
Ich hab mich extra zurückgehalten für die Sendung.
Eine Stunde überzogen.
Das Betrinken, das geht ja jetzt los in der Lounge.
Aber wir können ja das erstmal alle machen.
Naja, das machen wir hier gleich mit unseren Freunden hier vor Ort zu ändern.
Okay.
Soll einfach auf die Bühne kommen oder was?
Nee, wir müssen jetzt erstmal die Sendung sozusagen auch zu einem Ende führen.
Zu einem positiven. Dieser Mexikaner ist mir am Hals stecken geblieben.
Wir haben euch alle lieb und einhörner. Ist das positiv?
Ich hab euch kaputt gespielt.
Ich merke es sofort.
Nee, hast du nicht. Aber spiel mal ab oder was auch immer du da hast.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab nur noch so ein bisschen so einen kleinen Weihnachtsausklang mir noch gesucht, der zum Thema passt. Ja.
Das ist noch fast zwölf Monate hin, Mann.
Ich brauch jetzt mal wieder meinen Screen hier irgendwie. Ja klar, ich meine, ihr habt ja jetzt keine nennenswerten Ideen mehr auf den Tisch.
Wieso, wir reden noch die ganze Zeit auf dich ein und du?
Du, ich hab hier jede Menge Hardware auf die Bühne geschleppt.
Ja, ist ja gut. Aber hast du noch welche zu zeigen? Nee, ist doch alles durch.
Ich hab meinen Soll erfüllt, glaube ich.
Ja genau, wir haben alle unseren Soll erfüllt.
Na dann.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, fangen wir ja langsam mal an, das Ende einzuleiten. Achso, dazu muss ich ja auch noch mal hier.
Das ist natürlich, jedes Ende ist natürlich auch ein Anfang.
Ja, um jetzt nochmal die positive Note mit dem letzten.
Genau.
Nach dem Ende ist vor dem Anfang.
Womit ich meine, wir treffen uns alle gleich in der Lounge und haben Spaß.
Genau, das ist das, was wir machen. Und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen, bedanken wir uns mal erstmal hier bei euch, ja, für das tolle Mitmachen und das tolle Feedback geben, Sachen schicken und was nicht alles ist super. Macht richtig großen Spaß mit der ganzen Community, diese Sendung zu machen und wir machen weiter. Und mit der 200, müsst ihr mal ein paar gute Ideen bringen und vielleicht decken wir uns noch was raus.
Keiner tippt Kopfhörer. Drahtlos mit Leuchttioden.
Ja, ich brauch den Link. Ich suche auch noch mal das Video raus.
Die Seidenstraße ist wieder am Start.
So, wieso höre ich jetzt eigentlich nichts hier?
Letztes Jahr war mehr la meta.
Mein Audio ist nicht an, kann das sein?
Leute, rot, ich versuche hier eine professionelle...
Eine normale Freak Show. Jedes Mal.
Habt ihr mich drauf oder nicht?
Jedes Mal.
Jaja, ist Bild in Output.
Ich hatte gerade so einen Knistern irgendwie auf dem Kopf.
Du hast einen Knistern im... Macht mich fertig. Ja, ich weiß nicht, spielt jetzt nicht. Siehst du mal? Ich hatte Recht, ne?
So, so endet die Sendung.
Natürlich.
Huckel.
Das war Huckel, die Stimme der Jugend. Dennis, Bitcoin-Millionär. Roddy das Einhorn. Und ich, Tim, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Bis bald.
Willkommen.
Thank you for coming.